el nombre corto de la enfermedad
conocida como la nueva enfermedad del
corona virus de 2019 los coronavirus son
un gran grupo de virus similares
se sabe que algunos infectan a los seres
humanos como el sars kof y elmer scoop
el que causa la cob y 19 se llama 6,2
todos los coronavirus reciben su nombre
por las espigas que cubren su superficie
llamadas espigas o proteínas s dentro
del virus el material genético llamado a
rn está compuesto de genes los genes
llevan la información para hacer más
copias del virus
el virus puede infectar los ingresa a la
boca la nariz o los pulmones
en el interior del organismo la proteína
s del virus se une a un receptor en la
superficie de una de las células esto
puede desencadenar que el virus entre en
la célula de dos maneras puede hacer que
el virus se fusione con la superficie de
la célula y que luego libere sus genes
en esta
y la célula puede arrastrar el virus
hacia el interior encerrándolo en un
saco una vez dentro el virus puede
fusionarse con el saco y liberar sus
genes a continuación los genes utilizan
una estructura en la célula llamada
ribosoma para hacer nuevas copias del
virus los nuevos virus viajan a la
superficie de la célula
y ahí salen para infectar más células
mientras tanto las proteínas virales s
que quedan en la superficie de la célula
infectada pueden hacer que se fusione
con las células sanas cercanas formando
una célula gigante esta puede ser otra
forma de que el virus se propague entre
las células las personas pueden estar
infectadas con la cob y 19 de 2 a 14
días antes de que aparezcan los síntomas
los tres síntomas principales de la cob
y 19 son fiebre tos y dificultad para
respirar otros síntomas pueden incluir
cansancio dolores corporales congestión
nasal dolor de garganta diarrea y
vómitos pérdida de apetito y pérdida del
olfato
la mayoría de las personas tiene una
forma leve de la enfermedad y puede
recuperarse en casa algunas personas que
tienen el virus pueden no enfermarse en
absoluto o pueden no mostrar ningún
síntoma pero si tiene problemas para
respirar o cualquier otro síntoma grave
llame a su médico oa la sala de
emergencias ellos le dirán que hacer
para la mayoría de las personas que
tienen el virus se cree que el riesgo de
padecer esta enfermedad de manera grave
es bajo las personas de 65 años o más
pueden tener un mayor riesgo de padecer
la enfermedad de forma grave y las
personas de cualquier edad pueden correr
un riesgo mayor si tienen condiciones
subyacentes como enfermedad pulmonar
crónica o asma enfermedades cardíacas
graves diabetes obesidad grave
enfermedad renal crónica y enfermedad
hepática
los grupos de alto riesgo también
incluyen a las personas con el sistema
inmunológico debilitado quienes toman
ciertos medicamentos como los
corticosteroides las personas en
tratamiento contra el cáncer y quienes
tienen vih o sida
aunque no esté en un grupo de alto
riesgo es importante practicar el
distanciamiento social lo que significa
mantener al menos dos metros de
distancia o seis pies entre usted y
otras personas esto ayuda a prevenir
infecciones y enfermedades graves en los
demás así como en uno mismo
para obtener información actualizada
sobre la cob y 19 y otras formas de
prevenir su propagación visite el sitio
web de los cdc en cdc punto gov
coronavirus 2019
v